Hey ladies and gentlemen my name is Ryan
right I'm Lauren gah and tonight we're
gonna watch a special little trailer do
you know we're gonna watch Lauren
guardians of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy that doesn't like pretending
you're supposed to go what what is it
back again you know we're gonna watch
tonight Lauren what are we gonna why
guardians of the galaxy shut the front
door
I know oh oh okay those therapeutic for
me thank you again second trailer people
are stoked for this movie
why talk anymore let's do it just watch
it come on
okay I'm going this show on the road I'm
trying all day here
tick tock man it's plain it's been
approved lang Shh
Wow come from a planet about laws
weddings I love Chris Pratt no matter
what else works in rectly yeah not
star-lord man legendary outlaw guys
forget it just me like sarcastic Wow the
effects like this looks like a cool
science fiction picture
oh yeah so here we are be Flynn is there
any standbys evil white 7e galaxy I
guess we're stuck together
I'm Chris Pratt of in this group we're
gonna wrap criminal Mike Nelson
yeah
doing I don't know they're defending
universe in the world somehow
look how cool this looks I'm looking
it's kick-ass a chance
hell yeah sometimes you
oh I don't got that long a lifespan
anyway
this is going to be one of the best
movies
sexy nothing like me set big big homes I
want to be the galaxy
I wanna three-legged dog the best idea
Oh awesome looks like a really cool
movie it looks like a ton of Awesome
oh yeah the effects look great it just
looks like a ton of fun like it's
entertainment at its best right there
you know what it's best at its best and
I know this from a trailer summer
blockbuster we're all we're gonna do is
put in special effects in like tight
people that is not what a lot of maybe
that it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
humorous I'm sure there's gonna be some
real badass emotional moments yeah yeah
there's nothing really badass emotional
moments and they're gonna like get
really deep yeah and they're gonna come
together hold the heartstrings yeah
would you guys shut up or filming some
rude ass neighbors probably Hispanics
cuz that is a right of them ok that's
really racist what you just said it's
not racist what if it's true
I'm just kidding guys I know a lot of
you are Hispanic I take it all back
especially Michelle Fernandez what if
she's not as good she is asthmatic she's
Cuban I've asked ok so they just based
on her name you can't say that she what
if she's not no no I
Michelle has brought up a lot on this
channel ok why I got a little special
crush on the show
oh is that that girl you're talking
about why'd you make that face right so
that girl you're talking about it again
someone's jealous
totally Lauren please you have a
boyfriend
let's not let's not do this okay it's
not making comments are ya let's face it
I am way out of your league
how dare you yeah I was laughing because
it's funny because it's true yeah
guardians of the galaxy the performances
look like they're gonna be awesome Tim
you know it's like they got cool [__]
action characters may have a lot of good
actors in it they have a lot of good
people oh yeah totally it's kind of
unexpected casting to which I really
like that doesn't even sound like
Bradley Cooper but it's good it is I
wouldn't have guessed that a lot of
times you can hear it at that time I was
like same thing with Vin Diesel's voice
yes but he also didn't really talk yeah
oh my god you're gonna meet my neighbor
oh my god breezy hi Marie
anyway Marie Kayla Frank get get out of
our video yeah
visual effects action everything about
it looks like it's gonna be fun what I
love most about it is all these Marvel
movies have such serious [__]
trailers and this is the first one and
forever where it's like this is gonna be
fun
a lot of humor in it it's not taking
itself too seriously exactly you know
x-men which I'm excited for because I
love all the x-men movies but it's like
oh well we gonna do like we have to go
back in time and uh you know like it's
exactly that's your impression of the
x-men franchise like hey I'm Wolverine
man I'm gonna fight no but pretty much
it's like I'm overrated I'm walking and
I'm really serious
Shing that's pretty much that's pretty
much what the trailer is they're good
Wolverine Colossus that's also the
dominating oh by the way she's gonna
review x-men Days of Future past with us
so keep a lookout for that this weekend
you just slightly graze my knee with
your fingers that was oh my god ah yes
okay a little lower
Oh what the hell you stopped that was
the most sex I've had in months that's
really sad for him no it's just a fact
summary dude your face is so red I enjoy
putting coconut oil on a rash animated
ten times worth last week but it's just
of antibacterial properties
it's supposed to that's X I'm sorry
better guess are you having fun here
yeah blast okay when is the last time
you have a coconut oil on your skin I
use it every night do you
yeah right before I go to bed what are
they Conservation Jim oh that's gross
it's not a half the time I think about
you it's okay if you're new to the
channel Oh subscribe subscribe click the
button up there can you can you put it
anywhere you want yeah I could literally
put a dating of it like here sure like
scribe n yeah block my whole face okay
bed I don't want count I'm gonna make it
so you like new Veteran's gonna be like
it's a game yeah this created a
subscribe game mmm Leah Vaughn
hi Leah it won't let me reply back to
your comments Oh No which makes me look
like an [__] when you're on the page
where I'm like huh reply reply reply I'm
gonna skip over Leah the reply reply
reply sorry Leah you don't get a reply
yeah it's actually intentional I can
totally reply back he's lying right now
it's useless doesn't want to reply to
you there's something about your name
that is just not
I'm gone and men's e of life and I like
this I like Vince Vaughn - you know what
Lee I'm gonna start back to your shell
oh yeah or princess Lou we uh closed the
no cigar just fix your [__] account
so I can reply back to you Google+ maybe
she doesn't want you to reply maybe she
does want to hear from you why would you
say that maybe she did that on purpose
ha ha
Nathan Rojas Nathan he said if Godzilla
is king of monsters then Ryan is king of
reactions oh that is so kind of you I
work hard at what I do
watching trailers and expressing how I
feel when I watch them I am the king of
that apparently I should I should get
like a Burger King crown
those were a cool you know I'm talking
about the look what do you know what
you're talking about those were awesome
I wonder if they still give those out
you'd wear like a tiara I have a tiara I
could loan you you know I might be one
of the few people like to pull off a
tiara whaa anyway Nathan thanks buddy
you're really sweet to say that you're
the king of my heart oh yeah
should I leave do you want some alone
time with me Benny I think about Nathan
when I used to coconut oil in it yeah
Louise Duran lui he said I inspired him
to do his own videos
oh cool ah I'm laughs that's what I do
Louie it's just common here it's what
you think you're so special all this up
I'm kidding man that is so awesome so
seriously I feel really good when people
say something like that yeah no thank
you that you have no idea how nice that
is to actually hear it know you're king
of reactions all right oh yeah
not just trailer reactions oh yeah trust
me watch let's let's do this all right
just say sentence and I will react just
keep dishing out sentences today I went
to the store nice I bought a sandwich
what kind of sandwich turkey and cheese
that sounds delicious and then I got
some Oreos mmm Oh yum yum yum yum yum
the mint oreos who's sexy
but there was a really long line at the
checkout counter oh how boring and I
forgot my reusable shopping bag oh don't
you hate it when that happens but I
could carry everything I didn't need a
bag that's true there's a there's a
positive there and then I went home and
ate my sandwich Andorian nah ending on a
good note